foreign
good evening
welcome to the table we are glad that
you're here my name is Don Jacobs I'm
part of the leadership team that's here
at the church and I'm just glad it's
thrilled to see so many of you guys here
um I have to admit something I finally
have gotten to the age where I have to
kind of blow up things on my phone
because I have to kind of do this in
order to read
it's not fun not fun being the stage
right now but I'm just yeah to remember
to do now now I can see the
announcements yeah but yeah things are
just really big on my phone I'm just not
used to this this is crazy anyway
uh do you have a few announcements to uh
just to remind you a couple of things so
we do have uh t-shirts
um or being pre-ordered right now
they're about twenty dollars
um next week's gonna be the last week to
be able to get that in
um and we're hoping to have the t-shirts
in the um right before our third
anniversary of the table and the
centerpiece conference so if you want to
order that make sure you do that you can
do that online I think it's been sent
out through the socials and also uh
Brett's weekly uh e-letter so just pay
attention to them
um also not next Sunday but the Sunday
after so in two weeks we're gonna just a
quick uh service change so instead of
doing our evening normal evening service
we're actually going to be doing service
with Pleasant Valley
um at 11 A.M and so we're going to be
celebrating their
160th anniversary that's amazing 160th
that's amazing love that
um also after that there's going to be
like a barbecue lunch so if you might
want to stick around for that sounds
amazing
and then the last thing um trick or
treat is going to be in a couple weeks
uh start time is gonna yes
uh start time is going to be at 6 30
um that evening
um it's gonna be a Friday it's the 28th
so the last Friday of the month this
month and then of course you can
participate decorating your car get it
giving handy
um that type of stuff
um Brittany put a sign up sheet in the
very back of the table so if you want to
go ahead and sign up for that you can
take advantage of that and then of
course I'm sure there's going to be a
place online at some point so you can
also do that there as well so with that
being said let's do a quick order career
we'll go start it
Laura thank you so much for this time
together in this ability to get together
to come and to just be a church and a
people that love you
we're just so much of a desperate need
to connect not just with each other but
just to kind of remember who we are
because of what you have done for us and
who you tell us we are I pray that you
just open our hearts and our minds to
this time and worship and the award is
going to be shared later on this evening
in Christ I am praying amen
things done well if you guys will stand
with us we're going to go ahead and kick
off with some music to start our time
together and if this is your first time
um we are glad you're here and there's
space for you in this worship set to sit
back and listen or to engage but I just
encourage you to bring your whole self
whatever that looks like tonight
whatever's going on it's welcome here
and there's room for your life there's
room for your story
um and I hope that in those moments as
you're bringing everything to this space
with you I hope that you find God in the
middle of it I hope you feel his
closeness and his presence with you and
his love so um this first song Let's
just if you feel comfortable let's clap
our hands just because it helps
sometimes to engage our body into things
so that we can help ourselves connect
with what's going on and be present in
this moment so if you guys feel
comfortable this is a great one to clap
along to and I'll go ahead and join in
that as well at the beginning so you can
follow me
[Music]
I love you
these trees
breathing again
[Music]
we dream of you
a piece of burdens
we are children
of Grace
[Music]
we dream of you
on country roads
stalling along with our friends
[Music]
living behind
flickering scream
to be together again
[Music]
we are children
a Grace
and the blue
in our colors
is
[Music]
all right you guys follow me
babies roll up
[Music]
let the people sing the songs
[Applause]
[Music]
we are children
of Grace
is a garment
of praise
burden
we are children
of Grace
[Music]
here we go
let the people sing the songs
[Music]
foreign
we're going to transition into our
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right I'm gonna lead us in our
prayers of the people if you guys would
read along with me and when we come to
this space in the middle if there's
someone or something that you're
carrying on your heart that you would
like to lift up with us this is a time
for us to shoulder each other's burdens
and to bring what we're carrying in
front of Jesus and trust and believe
that he is with us in the midst of that
and if you're joining us online please
feel free to leave
whatever you have on your heart in the
comments and we will share those with
the room
read this with me for the city of Sachse
Texas and for every city and community
and all of those who live in them
pray to you for The Good Earth that you
have given us and the wisdom and the
will to conserve it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the Widow and the orphan for the
injured and suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you Lord we know that you
love us and that you hear us and so we
lift these names and situations up to
you
[Music]
foreign
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
foreign
below me before and behind me in every
eye that seems
[Music]
by myself
Christ be all around me
[Music]
all around me
forever
[Music]
let's flip that out together
this guy
[Music]
go to the water
all who are thirsty
[Music]
those who are weary
those who are needing
received
[Music]
all who are thirsty
come and dreams
come to the table
all who are hungry
those who are needing
[Music]
your received
Come to the River
[Music]
oh
my soul
there is
[Music]
see that you are good
I will taste and see the you are good
I will taste
and see that you are good you're good
I will taste and see that you are good
[Music]
I will days
oh
my soul there's for you alone
[Music]
I love myself
come to the wider
all who are thirsty
come and dreams
come to the table
all who are hungry
[Music]
I'm so grateful that he's made room for
each one of us
and he's invited each one of us
[Music]
to come as we are
to be loved
[Music]
to find him faithful
I was thinking as we were practicing
earlier tonight and
[Music]
um
just remembering the moments where
where I encounter stress or concern
fears in my life and just wondering what
would it be like if instead of turning
to my own vices if I was running towards
God's best for me
what would it be like in our moments of
stress if we were to stop and access the
fruits of his Spirit instead of the
fruits of our culture
foreign
[Music]
tic stress what if I were to access his
peace
if I could slow myself down
and make space to feel his peace
and to trust him
instead of the need to run to others or
gossip what if I was to stop and make
room for self-control and for silence
centering
in his love
love
God tonight we look towards your best
[Music]
towards love and joy
towards your peace
towards patience
towards self-control
God we ask that you would fill us up
with your nature and your character and
that you would remind us to find you
to look for you
to make space for you
[Music]
in our stress in our busyness in our
chaos or our fears
would we look for you in our anxiety
in our depression
in our relationships
[Music]
in our finances
would we turn towards you
and just as you've invited us into your
story God would we invite you into ours
would you be present with us
would you change and transform us
[Music]
thank you God for your grace as we learn
how to walk out the gospel as we learn
how to be followers of Jesus
thank you that we are met with
unconditional love
we want more of you in our lives God
[Music]
help us to follow
it's in your name I pray all these
things and thank you for this time
together amen
would you guys turn to the people around
you and say hello make them feel welcome
and then you can have a seat and Brett
will get us started for the message
that wasn't funny
oh Grace and peace
Grace and peace it's good to be with you
all
and uh I want to extend a warm welcome
to all of you that as always includes
those join us online thanks for being
with us and anyone here who is new kind
of making their way either into the
community or just maybe just visiting
we're really really glad to have you
with us Jesus was maybe the most
hospitable welcoming person that ever
lived in fact we'll get more into that
as we get in the message and so we seek
to live into that same hospitality and
we just want you to know
um you're not like tolerated you're not
you know coming in it's like oh we kind
of have our group you know no no we're
really really glad that you're you're
here so thank you for being with us so
um we are in uh the series we're
actually starting to wrap it up this
will be the final Thurman
um in the the series uh titled unclean
Drawing Near in a runaway world
and uh kind of throughout this series
we've been drawing on a book by
um a Christian psychologist and author
named Richard Beck uh and the book is of
the same title unclean different
subtitle
um and the the kind of premise of the
book
is uh studying something called
discussed psychology and if you've been
with us for the series you're very
familiar with this term by now
um but discuss psychology is basically
the human Oso human reaction we have two
things that we find revolting or
disgusting in fact
um I saw someone post from someone from
the table post on Facebook this week
they had accidentally eaten some moldy
bread and I'm not going to say who
because I didn't ask the permission but
they were reacting okay Miriam's
pointing to herself so she's kind of
calling herself out so it was Miriam and
it's just that uh with the very dramatic
I must add like with the think water
just like ah I like trying to clean it
right so that's the disgust psychology
no you might think well what on Earth
does it have to do with the Bible
um well the the trick is the way that we
shift from finding things disgusting and
through our moral imaginations through
the metaphors that we choose to describe
something wrong
we come to view people
that's the transition that's the uh we
might also say the danger as we've
unpacked week after week after week
um there's there's a lot of danger in
that move because it's one thing to be
like oh moldy bread disgusting that's
another thing entirely to think in terms
of people
or even a group of people
as like revolting disgusting toxic
unclean right that's it's a huge problem
so kind of throughout the series we've
been coming back to this uh this little
vignette this whole story of The Life of
Christ from Matthew chapter 9 verses 9
through 13 and uh it's a story about him
in the Pharisees and you'll see all this
play out it says this as Jesus went on
from there he saw a man named Matthew
sitting at the tax collector's Booth
follow me he told him Matthew got up and
followed him while Jesus was having
dinner at Matthew's house many tax
collectors and sinners came and ate with
him and his disciples when the Pharisees
saw this they asked his disciples
why why does your teacher eat with tax
collectors and sinners on hearing this
and notice how Jesus shifts the metaphor
on hearing this Jesus said well it is
not the healthy who need a doctor but
the sick
but go and learn what this means I
desire Mercy not sacrifice
for I have not come to call the
righteous but sinners
it's a beautiful story
um
so tonight uh the title of my message is
learnings from the book unclean I want
this to be kind of um it's not so much a
summary but what I want to do is dive
into some things that I might have just
touched on or briefly mentioned and I
want to take an opportunity to kind of
unpack it or maybe there was like
something that's sort of been implied or
um implicit in this theories but I
haven't named it and so I want to make
it like explicit not in the sense of
like I won't curse a lot or anything but
you know what I mean like really draw it
out
um and so that's kind of where we're
we're going to go tonight
um so but the way I'll frame this we'll
do three takeaways tonight
three takeaways take away number one uh
when I simply
feel in my bones
that a thing is wrong or a person is
morally or socially impure
beware it might be discussed psychology
kicking in uh by feeling my bones here
what I basically mean is
um if if there's kind of a situation and
I can't really clearly articulate or
name the harm or the Injustice in it
that
that's a moment
where I need some self-awareness and
prayerful reflection
because that's a moment where it's it
could very be well be it's just it's
discussed psychology kicking in and all
of a sudden I may find myself against
someone or a group of someone's that in
um were my anxiety not all riled up I
might actually make a very different
decision
that makes sense so we have to be I
think really really careful here now
this is this point isn't that you'd say
like that's what the whole series is
about this is not fresh territory well
here's where I want to take it this is
um something that has been kind of
implied throughout the series but I want
to name it clearly uh is uh the way this
relates specifically to
um sexual orientation and church
theology
um because of course uh well let me back
up so Richard Beck uh he wrote this book
and he himself he is gay affirming in
theologically
um but the book itself isn't so much
about that however maybe just in like
two or three places
he just mentions it now he hails from a
wing of the church known as Church of
Christ and so it's a very conservative
denomination
um and he teaches at Abilene Christian
University again pretty fairly
conservative so I think it's probably on
purpose that he's not just like
really out there with it but it was
interesting because I didn't necessarily
expect him to bring it up but I caught
the two or three times when he did and I
think it's a really interesting angle
because
um what he clarifies is that at one
level like okay yes
um
that topic like we basically he
clarifies why it's been so hard and
difficult for
um not just the world but even church
folks and but he names why it's it's not
just a theological challenge it's not
just like well there's term scriptures
certain scriptures they read scripture
they're scriptures right it's not just
about a a doctrine of scripture or an
exegesis of Leviticus or Romans 1 or
whatever
um it's not it's not just about that
there's there's something else going on
and I think Beck's book is an extended
essay in exactly what that something
um is and in essence it's um it's about
it's discussed psychology it's this
visceral reaction that and this is why
it's sort of strange like people will um
uh often be just somewhat baffled
Bamboozled like why we'll get actually
more of this in a second like why is the
church so obsessed with sex
why is it like that's like the thing and
we just you know whereas for example
someone could um
like embezzle 10 million dollars
and just ruin a thousand lives
and we're like wow yeah good but
forgiven I'm being Elder in the church
you know it's like it's like not this
this morally it just doesn't stir us up
right
um and it's interesting like you could
even see how we can um we have no
problem really reinterpreting scriptures
that that don't necessarily
um connect with our culture in the same
way right we'll be like well that was
that was
um we'll reinterpret I mean or honestly
well even kind of ignore like I'm
thinking uh for example passages
from uh Jesus himself on like say
divorce
where it's like hey only in the case of
adultery that's the only grounds for
divorce
um and yet as time has gone on
we've kind of there's and there's a
whole theological reason as to why this
is but for example someone uh steps into
my office metaphorically I have no
office but just say standard one and I
was counseling with them and they had
been there's a lot of physical abuse in
the relationship
um there is no way I would be like
trying to drastically talk them out of
like oh no haven't you read Jesus words
right well and why well there's a
there's a whole interpretation that goes
into his thing right and if you know
some of the background it's because
Christ is trying to protect women in
that culture and so there's like a whole
thing right as to why and then based on
that why then you say well if the point
is to protect people and so on and so
forth right you can see in other words
we have these teachings and people
interpret wrestle with it make sense of
it so my point is it's interesting that
in these other areas we have we just
haven't seen to have all that much
trouble kind of doing that
right but all of the sudden
when it comes to this topic
this area or this or the lgbtq plus
Community like then all of a sudden
it's been a huge challenge for the
church like big deal why
so I think at the level of like hearts
and Minds
you know when it comes to a lot of
ethics and morals it's something we like
it's not so much about our prefrontal
cortex and like oh have you done a
thorough exegesis of Leviticus 18 just
not about that
what's it about it's about the gut
and we and we start feeling in our bones
like why just feel on my bones
we start going down that road we got to
be really really careful
next book is a brilliant analysis of
exactly why this is so
um I just want to name
clearly since I've been like a few weeks
in this series and
maybe haven't explicitly named it
um if you're part of that Community
you're loved
seen you are no
more impure unclean than anyone else
like you're just a human being and we
love you
and man I hope you know like
Christ is in you
You're Made In God's image
and
I want you to feel
like a full human being
not Lester not like second tier no
no
this is um I'll just speak on behalf of
the the
straight folks this has been our issue
it's our own guts and our own it's our
own stuff
um
now as I kind of alluded to earlier it's
not just about sexual orientation though
really this kind of parallels are not
perilous but it leads into
sex in general and things that that we
would all agree maybe are like a sin of
some sort sexual sin or something
um and it names his book really names
like why yeah why is the church so
obsessed with sex why are we just
struggling like when it comes to that
again someone can embezzle and we're
like well you know just on the wrong
path you know but something around
sexuality and it's like oh gosh
maybe it's the unforgivable thing you
know why
um I think it's it's around because
there's something about I think
sexuality that is so bodily and so as we
talked about a few weeks ago metaphors
right metaphor I think something around
sexuality it lends itself to Purity
metaphors and thus really lends itself
to kind of disgust
um in in folks whereas
other sins so to speak other you know
embezzling or whatever it just doesn't
it's just kind of like oh they're just
they just made a mistake everyone makes
a mistake you know and it's sort of like
move on
um but there this is I think this is why
uh and I hope to uh we're gonna do some
panel discussion next week I hope to to
get more into that in a practical way so
all right so that's that's the first
thing uh when I feel in my bones that
beware
beware second takeaway is emphasize
positivity dominance over negativity
dominance so we touched on this in week
one but I want to unpack a little bit
more
um so the idea of negativity dominance
is basically where in the in the
physical world we tend to
see that which is negative or polluted
or unclean or impure as the stronger
Force
more so than the pure the clean and so
on so for example um I named week one
this is why if you drop your napkin at
the restaurant
you don't celebrate right you don't say
oh good that floor looks so dirty I'm so
glad Eminem can like clean it up a
little bit so let me get that because
it's cleaning but don't worry it's this
is still fine you know when you're up no
you would not do that correct I hope not
oh it's name if you drop your steak on
the ground you don't say like oh good my
perfectly pure sirloin steak has cleaned
the floor hooray you know no it's the
opposite why because that floor is so
powerful
like when it comes to the biological
physical world the pollutant that's
where the power lies that which is pure
um that which is clean oh vulnerable
vulnerable all right even if your napkin
fell for just a second some of you have
the 10 second rule maybe not at a
restaurant no more tense like who would
still do the 10 second rule at a
restaurant no one's maybe somewhere like
um no one wants to confess to it but you
get what I'm saying right that's the
power now
um the trick is the way that this
when via our moral imaginations
we are now no longer talking about
things but people it's interesting that
the same logic in our minds tends to
hold
even though with people and emotions and
relationships and our actual living
it is way more of a two-way street
but it's it's interesting to see how
um and this again can really happen in
the church where we start to see like oh
that person or that group oh they're
unclean there they're not on the right
path they're not living God's way and
all of a sudden it's like damn change
your danger danger danger like oh stay
away you can really get pulled in to the
bad ways you know
um and
uh of course I mean there's some truth
in that right like I don't know there's
the whole Book of Proverbs like good
company or bad company corrupts good
morals
we know it can do that and this is why I
wouldn't suggest if someone I don't know
like a maybe former alcoholic is like I
want to start a bar Ministry a bar
evangelism I'd be like I don't know man
maybe not
um you know for that because there's
there's something to or maybe with our
young people or something we're like hey
you have some good friends you know
um because we know there's easily
influenced but it just it does it gets
strange though when even as adults where
even us whole churches are like building
The Fortress
you know keep them away and what's going
on there it's it's a negativity
dominance point of view but here's the
truth
that is not how Jesus lived
can I get an amen
and it's not how we are called to live
like think of this your goodness your
peace your great love and compassion is
contagious
isn't that good news like it's
contagious it's it's positivity
dominance rather than oh the negative oh
the unclean the impure that's the thing
right
um there's a beautiful uh example of
this from Matthew chapter eight where
Jesus lives this out it says when Jesus
came down from the Mountainside large
crowds followed him a man with Leprosy
came and knelt before him and said Lord
if you're willing you can make me clean
Jesus reached out his hand and touched
the man I'm willing he said be clean
immediately he was cleansed of his
leprosy
uh I had read this story probably a
hundred times and it wasn't until
reading Richard Beck that he pointed out
the order I mean I was always struck
that Jesus touched the man
you know I was that always struck me
what I didn't notice was the order of it
did you catch it it's he reaches out he
touches the man and then what does he
say
be clean
you see the significance of that I mean
why not be clean
laughs
right basically I pronounce you cleaned
in the name of me you know and then no
it's the touch
and then the cleansing follows
I think there that's a picture
of our call
um of our Church's call
that's who we're called to be be people
who reach out and touch and connect
in other words love
the friend
before expecting the transformation the
life change the get on my page believe
like me think like me act like me and be
you know clean up your life
the touch almost always comes first
love comes first man what how different
would the church's reputation be if we
like I don't just mean the table but
even extended broader Church all of us
like if we actually lived that
touch and then the cleansing follows
what's that a picture of it's positivity
dominance
it's I'm not worried about being
corrupted
I'm gonna love and allow that love that
peace that joy that healing to be
contagious
live like you're contagious
in a good way
um third our third takeaway the church
has been given powerful anti-discus
practices
utilize them
utilize them I'm going to give you three
of them so many points in this message
I like pointless turns not this one this
is lots of points
um so a in person
uh Sunday worship
you know it strikes me um of course we
have some folks online and that is
wonderful reasons for for some of them
it's geography for others it's like
illness or various reasons they can't be
here and that's fine
um but I will say there is something
about the um physicality the bodily
nature of much Christian worship
especially historically that it does it
like brings us all together
here and it just kind of bursts our
little Bubbles doesn't it
um and we are kind of a Huggy Church you
probably know maybe noticed
um and I I think
um well we want to be sensitive to folks
in their preferred ways of you know
greeting that's fine but there is
something about um like for example you
can go to work all week you can go to
the grocery store and it's like you just
have this buffer you know the especially
Americans I've heard culturally we have
a very large buffer as compared to other
cultures where they're very comfortable
you know getting like Latin America and
it's like oh wow we're all just right
here you know um so it's kind of
different the West is different but we
have very big buffers
and there is something I think really
beautiful and Powerful about coming to
church and suddenly it is hugs and
handshakes and different kinds of people
people we might not have interacted with
in our own neighborhood or like it's
just it kind of forces us into that and
it can be challenging but I think it is
good in fact I remember
um right after the coveted vaccine was
widely available
and we had our first service after that
and it was like the hugs came back
anyone remember like this Sunday or two
like your first time back maybe for some
of you was just being back in church but
then it was like the hugs began again
and I was almost I had to kind of
relearn like oh yeah that's right we can
be close to people you know it was like
a year of like hey why five you know
just a distance everything and suddenly
we're back and that was incredibly
powerful I realized like after a year of
not doing it just what a what a powerful
practice that is I think it helps us um
burst that bubble it helps us get close
again so it's a baby step
so that's the first one in-person Sunday
worship
um second is hospitality and table
Fellowship this of course we already
recovered in Jesus story Matthew 9.
there he is you eat with tax collectors
and sinners you know
um I love there's a little quote by the
author Leonard sweet he summarized the
ministry of Jesus in this way he said
Jesus ate good food with bad people
and uh now for our purposes of our
series kind of expand on bad think a
little more poetically
um for those you know it's kind of
anyone that um outside our Circle of
Care so we talked about a few weeks ago
it could be maybe ask yourself who is
someone that my tribe
whether it's the church tribe or uh
uh
family tribe
um class level chart whatever think of
someone that that a tribe you
participate in to them or to that group
of people they say no
no not welcome
and then what would it look like for you
to say
yes
welcome for you to connect
Um this can look like as simple as
having them over for dinner
um or it can get incredibly radical
um one really like small way that that's
happening at the table I think there was
a someone who uh a mother of one of my
soccer players
I coach my oldest son's team the Bears
that's her name kind of cheesy but Bears
FC and uh and so there they have a son
and he's and he's incredibly good
um but his mother his whole family they
are um immigrants from part of the whole
uh Bosnia Croatia like they were their
families were caught up in all of that
conflict and so like his father had fled
a number of years maybe a decade ago but
then his mother
has just now came like over to the
states maybe a year ago
and so we were talking with her at last
year's
um
team party it's like just before the
summer
and we were asking her like hey she has
a new baby we're like oh it's so cute
you know it's wonderful and she you know
it's kind of challenging to communicate
just she's really just learning English
but we could kind of make it you know so
we're talking to her and we're like oh
that's so good and do you have time with
your baby and she's like oh yeah lots of
time you're like oh that's good and she
starts shaking her head no
she said no like not no like oh you're
there all day with your baby and she's
like it's not good too much time
and uh she went on to unpack that she
feels um she's isolated
and so we've been wanting to like get
them over for dinner or whatever and you
know life it just keeps happening so I
realized like Max we gotta do something
so I realized that there was a um a
young mom's Meetup that meets uh I think
it's now to Tuesdays or Wednesdays
that meets here um at the table and uh
led by Kelly Tilford my sister-in-law
and so I thought oh my gosh I'll invite
her there so last week
um she attended that Meetup
and
um
it went amazing like there she is
starting to find community in connection
I think that's a great example of
hospitality table Fellowship
with someone that they might not have
naturally ever connected with or known
and I'm no probably it kind of changed
the dynamic of the group because then
suddenly there's someone there who
doesn't speak English so well and that
changes how are you going to include
right
but that's the call
that's the goal I think of uh like a
really radical example of this is
um Daryl Davis I believe is his name he
is a blues musician some of you might
have heard of him he's all over the
Internet
um and he's an African-American man and
he um has taken the last 30 years
to intentionally reach out to the Ku
Klux Klan
he attends their rallies
and
he's trying to befriend them I mean talk
about like just a profound radical Brave
move I I honestly I don't think I have
categories for this
um
but he's been doing this now for 30
years
and what he does is he connects with him
and then he tries to eat with them
something about a meal
that connects and he said by the time
like once the little trust develops and
we start like kind of the Little
Beginnings of a friendship he said
almost inevitably they start to realize
that their hate has been misguided
and in 30 years he's now led over 200
klansmen to give up their robes
he then keeps them in his house
as a reminder
of the dent he's starting to make in
really extreme racism
um and I bring up this example not to
minimize other forms of racism other
systemic or other things but just as a
powerful example of radical Hospital
the Pharisees felt like wait what you're
eating with who
you know that's sort of us that's like a
modern exit like oh my wow wow uh that's
that's the call of the church
um last practice is communion communion
um we might never have thought of it but
actually communion is a really powerful
anti-disgust practice it also has no has
Notions of purity
and table Fellowship like if you think
of it and actually I've spoken with
someone or a few folks here who are
really new to Christian faith and
communion strikes them as rather bizarre
because it's like what I'm going to eat
Jesus you know I'm taking in the body of
Christ because I'm drinking his blood I
mean it's just weird you know so there
is I think there is there's elements
here of disgust of kind of like oh oh
wow I'm kind of having to take this in a
little bit like what's going on here
um
so there's kind of an element of disgust
there's also the Notions of purity
you have the idea here of Christ's
sacrifice the cross which
um heals and cleanses and restores and
forgives everyone
uh so there's Notions of Purity and then
but and remember though there's also
kind of Echoes of Jesus table Fellowship
every time we come to the table because
remember the first communion who is it
with
you had sitting there Judith
who would betray him you had Peter
doing just a few short hours would deny
him then you had the other disciples who
nearly all abandoned him
and yet he looks at them and he says
take and eat
this is my body broken for you this is
my blood shed for you
communion it's a it is a rich
Sacrament a powerful mystery and it's
it's amazing that every week we get to
connect and partake of it and and I
think it's a little bit of a training
in all those things discussed Purity
table Fellowship is kind of all
happening
um there in communion so as we come to
the table of the Lord tonight
as we take in the body of Christ the
blood of Christ
may we
do it as a people being made clean
being forgiven being healed and restored
and may we
engage this together
all of us
in all of our differences and different
theologies and perspectives and
um all the things that the world might
see a lot of uh division
but in Christ there's a Unity
so we do practice what's called an Open
Table meaning if you're here tonight and
you would like to participate you are
welcome to do that no one will be
checking your theological credentials
before you come forward
um we do serve gluten-free bread
the wine is non-alcoholic
it's also known as grape juice
so let me invite you to the table this
is a Celtic Christian invitation
this is the table not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow in you who
have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
foreign
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
come all proud
come all greedy come all lives come all
shame
I'm all wealthy come received to the
table come today
I'm all broken come on
come all pour it come all slaves come
all rulers
from all Sinners Come All Saints come to
the table
from here
[Music]
we saved you a sea
come to the bank
[Music]
every race
Every Nation come all Rebels come all
gay
the fringes come to Jesus for the table
full of grace
the table come and stay let's come to
the table
there's nowhere to Circle
come down with the King
reconnaissance
[Music]
come let down your God
you'll never
stranger
just come as you are
[Music]
behold
come be loved
come accept it
it's come now come
[Music]
come be home
come be
loved
come excited
come now come come
[Music]
it's coming
come now come
table
we're ready to feast
the party is waiting
[Music]
there's more still fears
go fill everything
go live out the nation
Kingdom of praise
[Music]
foreign
come and accepted
[Music]
come now come
come now now come
come come
[Music]
oh thank you guys
um thank you worship team
thank you Brent for those words as well
it's always kind of interesting to be a
queer person in this church when you
spend so much of your life in Church
spaces and not feel welcomed and not be
okay and always to be in a church space
and just there's something I can't talk
about it I can't say
the things that I wrestle with or the
things that I just have to be quiet
about it I can't talk about it and it
truly does anytime I've ever talked
about it it disgust people
and it was a very small group that I
could even begin to even talk about it
with
in process with and even then they
didn't want to know
they didn't want to hear about it and so
to hear from a song that we're closing
with tonight and talking about gay
people are welcome
you know the the welcome to the the uh
the service to the
Sports supper just just even that of
just being able to say that even those
who have tried and you failed
you're welcomed here
um I remember the first time Brett never
said that and I was like oh my gosh I
started crying immediately right there
um just because I've just that was one
of those things like if you were living
in sin you can't participate
there's so many barriers and to be in a
space where there's isn't
um
and I always was like when I tell people
talk about this it's like listen they
can handle gay people stuff they can't
handle all of your stuff too
so I mean so I appreciate this space a
lot I mean I can't I can I will never be
tired of being able to say how much I
appreciate being in this space and being
in this church and being with you all
y'all are amazing
um you all have you all are just people
I never get tired of being able to be
around to be able to talk to be able to
share things with and even hear some of
the things that you guys are just kind
of dealing with on a regular basis
um and that's what we're here for is to
lift each other up to pray for each
other to encourage each other and so
anyway with all that being said and as
you guys are dismissed I will be
standing in the bag so in case you need
a hug a high five a handshake just some
sort of word encouragement I'll be there
back there
um to do that for you
um
also just a couple reminders if you are
a visitor here we there is a place in
the back that we could uh you can fill
out is the back table out in the hallway
you can just fill out some basic
information slide into the box there we
just like to know that you're here I'm
just send you a message welcome just
over here
um and then just a couple again
reminders I mentioned before about
t-shirts and you know changing of
schedules for a couple Sundays from now
and shrunk or treat and there's a sign
up in the back don't forget all those
things
anyway with that being said if you feel
so comfortable and you want to stand to
read the seat the spinning addiction you
can or you can just remain in a posture
this you feel comfortable with
you are a child of God
and this is true in your best day and
it's true on your worst day
so as you go out into your weeks ahead
with the yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you were accepted
Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
[Music]
blessings see you guys next week
thank you
come to the table
come eat and drink
[Music]
come down with the King
regard at the table
come let down your gun
you're never a stranger
Come As You Are
[Music]
coming
come before
[Music]